let's just start by talking about what
happened in the pandemic in terms of
you like blew up give me a good pandemic
I was in Tennessee with my mom and uh
when they said we all had to stay home I
thought I'm going to stay here
and that was kind of a good decision but
not a good decision it had a lot of time
on my hand and I started posting on
Instagram and I did two posts a day I
think for 80 days and I would always
start it with well how y'all doing what
what this is awful you know we're just
stuck and just talk and talk and then
I don't know what happened people have
said to me what's the secret I have no
idea it would jump a million a day
a million a day what were you thinking
at that point well I was just thinking
by gosh who are these people
they want to hear what I have to say and
I think it's because I was a marketing
genius and didn't even know it because I
stayed away from politics religion I
didn't try to sell anybody anything I
just talked about you know what are
y'all doing here's what I'm doing I cut
my hair because I couldn't get the
barbershop I cut my hair on Instagram
one day I did you know just whatever was
going on I didn't think it through much
I certainly didn't rehearse yeah and uh
you know all of a sudden it's like
standing right now at 5.7 million or
something
it's like if you'd planned it it
probably wouldn't have worked exactly I
think that's it if I had sat down and
had a marketing team or yeah or or
something like that it was just uh
the innocence of it I guess I think so I
mean like I said I mean my my 24 year
old daughter came in and like stuck your
face in my face and said you got to
watch this
but I do it's nice I have people come up
to me and say you got me through that
you know I'm stuck at home with my kids
I thought I was going nuts and I would
look forward to just a minute or two
with you every day and I think that's
you know that's that's that's what
comedy's about they say that comedy is
tragedy two two weeks later
yes yes at one point you wanted to be in
Jockey but I mean where did where did
the acting bug come from
I got back I tried I really did I
exercised racehorses from the time I was
probably 19 yeah until late 20s and uh I
got tired of the travel you go you know
New York to Saratoga to Hialeah Park in
Miami and uh Canada and all over
wherever the horses went I went yeah and
everything I own could fit in an mg I
had a little convertible mg oh nice car
well it wasn't
I had a futon that would roll up and I
lived very nomadic but I thought this is
I'm getting too old for this so I went
back and I enrolled in journalism
classes at the University of Tennessee
at Chattanooga and they said you got to
get an Arts elective and someone said
take that intro to theater it said easy
a and I was not one who did plays in
high school or you know I was always
funny but that was to keep the bullies
at Bay I learned very early to to make
people laugh and I got up in that intro
to theater class and it just hit me like
a drug I mean I went I went to the head
of the department and I said tell me
what to do and he said well first let's
learn how to pronounce it it's not
theater
it's theater
that's what I said theater he said no
theater so I got a degree in theater and
in
1982 I think headed to California and
now why I didn't go to New York I can't
remember yeah with a theater degree you
think theater degree you said what was
it like 1400 bucks sewn into your shorts
yes sewn into my Underpants my mother
sounded into my drawers
I got a couple of commercials and and
got on a kind of a roll with that
solid for probably four years that's all
I did was
TV I was the pit printing guy I was the
elevator operator to Hamburger hail for
Taco Bell where you go if you don't eat
hamburgers I was I would list I used to
look at my old reel and see all that
stuff I did but I did commercials
forever and then my first job was
um the Fall Guy with uh Lee Majors I
don't know if you remember that I do
sure from years ago yeah that was your
first TV job yes yeah I played a
murderer and I pulled it off
what gave you the confidence to go to
California
I think
I don't know from a very early age I was
told I was special and you know yeah and
anything I did that got applauded and
you know I can remember getting to first
grade and figuring out I'm not that
special you know
but I maybe that was it just just Pat it
on the back and told I could achieve
anything from this little young kid and
I never I never thought twice you know I
never thought twice about anything I've
ever
gone after what was it like for you
growing up in the south
well you know I wasn't good at I was a
[ __ ] you know I was good at sports my
dad was a lieutenant colonel in the Army
he was a man's man and his you know
group of guys would come home and I'd be
twirling a baton in the front yard yeah
you know my mother had taught me she was
a champion baton twirling Daddy watch me
twirl and
he would you could just see he called me
son almost like he was in deep pain just
oh
son just can't come here won't you twirl
on the house I said Mama's scared I'll
break something I'll pay for whatever
you break just twirl
so I don't you know I've I've said it
was rough growing up but it wasn't
because I was a popular kid yeah you
know but I had a secret and that that
from the time you're about 14 years old
and you realize yikes you know you would
hear people you know use the word queer
or this and that and I think is that oh
it's like very disparagingly and you
think yikes that's me but
but let's just keep it on the down low
and my mother even I told her when I was
about 12 I said you know that I she
didn't even know I mean what could she
Liberace and and Paul Lee and on the
Center Square that's all there was to
compare it to and she's the the best
advice she gave me I thought she'd pull
out her Bible maybe yeah because we were
very devout she just said I think you'll
be subject to ridicule if you choose
this like like it's about Jews I chose
this
um she said I think you'll be subject to
ridicule and I couldn't bear that and so
just why don't why don't you just live
quietly
so here I am
how can you ask your son to live quietly
just a little church man I'll say right
um you lost your dad at 11 yeah
that was tough I bet
yeah and my sisters were nine he was in
the Army Reserves by that point and they
were flying to Hattiesburg Mississippi
to Camp Shelby I think it is for a
summer training camp and the plane went
down and there were five men killed one
of them had 10 kids but I think from
that event how it is reverberated
through our family
um
you know my life I wonder I wonder a lot
like what what would be different and
I've asked my mom that yeah do you think
what do you think how do you think Dad
she said your dad loved you so
unconditionally yeah he would have you
know he would have
he would have been fine but uh
yeah that's you know you you you do look
back and you wonder
but I will go home to Chattanooga
Tennessee and I still have people come
up to me in the grocery store and say
you've got to be Alan Jordan's boy yeah
something about the way I talk the way I
looked our our signatures
I saw something recently where he had
signed something I said that's uncanny
yeah that is uncanny
that my signature is exactly like my
dad's and I catch my mother looking at
me a lot you know and saying uh so much
so much like him
how does that make you feel when oh I
you know it saddens me but but it does
make me feel very proud because he he
was you know he was a superintendent of
the Sunday School yeah if he wasn't big
enough to play football then he was the
manager or the water board or something
and he was had never met a stranger yeah
we would go places and my dad would
introduce himself in the grocery line I
was kind of horrified I'm just a kid
he'd go hey buddy I'm Alan Jordan it's
my son Leslie Leslie stand up
I'd get down in there stop at a stop
light yeah he'd say hey bud what year is
that car and I'd get down
but talking to people I can't imagine
you being shy but you I know you are you
know when you're a kid you're just
awkward yeah you know when adults want
to ask you questions and stuff
you know I hated it
um you have reinvented yourself a bunch
of times which is not easy to do no how
do you do that well I it's not something
that just happens overnight you'll
you'll start thinking I remember one
time they sent me down and they said
there's two ways we can go here yeah we
can sell you like a a a personality yeah
you know where you can host things and
you can
um you know you can go that route yeah
or
you're a good actor and I said well I
kind of like to keep the ACT I mean
that's what I do that's what I'm good at
and somehow they both I do both now you
know how did you like La when you got
out there I loved it you know I found
West Hollywood and you know having grown
up in a very repressed Southern Baptist
atmosphere they were just queers hanging
from the trees
in fact that kind of got in the way a
little bit because you know there was
just a lot of carrying on and I'm
recovering alcoholic up for 25 years now
I never let it interfere with my work
but
you know there was a lot of caring on
running the streets and trying to keep
the balls afloat
like it's like you're suddenly in the
candy store it was uh it was a wonderful
time and then also
when I got to West Hollywood early on
all of a sudden we were a a city under
siege AIDS hit right and there was not a
lot of help we just couldn't really get
help and we figured out as a community
yeah we're gonna have to take care of
our own right and so I was right there
when they started like the AIDS project
Los Angeles in somebody's living room I
was right there when they started a
project angel food where we delivered
you know meals to people that couldn't
get out and you still have that sense
now of this community yes
um not so much anymore but but a real
sense of that this is we have to we have
to do it guys we have to do it we have
to take care of our own right you only
just bought an apartment I just bought a
condo after 40 Years of Living there and
it's on a hill overlooking West
Hollywood I'm now the king of West
Hollywood
it feels like the in some ways the
world's kind have opened up to you even
more in the last few years because of
this right what do you want from that
the only thing that Fame gives you is a
platform yeah and then you have to
decide am I going to give or am I going
to take and I want to give I want to
leave a mark in some ways but I want to
be of service you know you learn that in
recovery very early on but the way in
which to stay clean and to stay sober is
to be of service to another and that
takes you out of yourself I think that's
it that that I want to live a life of
service to other people and that gives
me happiness how do you see yourself
doing that well you know I'm I'm I'm
just available I remember
um the biggest lesson I ever learned in
acting was I went to my very first job
completely sober after I got clean and
and was Caroline in the city with Leah
Thompson yeah and I got a five episode
Arc and
um I said to my my sponsor at the time
my spiritual advisor
I've never really worked I don't he said
listen here's the way you approach it
this is the way you approach it you want
to be of loving service and I said oh
that's such you know new age I don't
know if you're going to pass out flowers
to people he said no no no you you you
you you're of loving service to the
director it's his vision yeah it's not
your vision you're there to serve the
director's Vision you can certainly
bring what you bring to the table but
you're you're there also to be of loving
service to the producers that means
you're on time you know your lines you
don't make waves you have to be of
loving service to your fellow actors
which means you don't steal the scene
yes me
and I went to work to be a worker among
workers and to to just be of service to
the project and I started working solid
yeah but now that you've got this
persona
it's like you're in charge of that yeah
and sometimes I get tired of that it's
like they'll say I'll do a tag or
something they go
where did that let do that Leslie Jordan
thing I said okay okay what I can do
whatever that is I don't know what is it
well it's just bright and bubbly and I
don't know I don't know what it is so
this musical Journey you're on here it
seems like you're having a lot of fun
with that oh my gosh
so unexpected just to happen at you know
in my 60s yeah
I'm a country music singer now
I love Nashville and the way that
Nashville
embraced me yeah I worried a little bit
you know you I love Tennessee I kind of
got ran out of Tennessee for being gay
chased out of Tennessee in my head but
to come back and be just fully embraced
and yeah you know that people in the
industry and to be taken kind of serious
yeah and to have made you know an album
with Dolly Parton Chris Stapleton yeah
Brandi Carlile yeah you know that's
that's something I and it happened so
quickly that I didn't really think it
through and now when I look back I think
whoa that's an accomplishment